I'm not going to read the book I haven't
read it I don't even know if it's out
yet Kelly Ripa's new book Livewire may
have just hit the shelves but one person
who has no plans of picking up a copy
Kathy Lee Gifford tough stuff on Monday
the former live with Regis and Kathy Lee
host sat down with Good Day New York and
said she wasn't too happy about the
headlines surrounding Kelly's book
specifically the ones Kelly wrote about
the nature of her relationship with
Regis Philbin who died in 2020. we had a
very professional working relationship
that used to be a celebrated thing but
in this weird Gonzo tabloidy let's pit
the man against the woman world that we
live in somehow that was straight it was
strange and I was vilified and so that's
why I address it in the book I was very
sorry to see the headlines you know it's
we see headlines all the time and I you
know you never know what's true and
what's not true I just minute I was in
Israel and I saw that and I went oh I
hope this isn't true I just hope it
isn't because what's the point
you know I don't get it I don't get it
I'm not going to read the book I haven't
read it I don't even know if it's out
yet Kathy Lee hosted live with Regis
from 1985 to 2000. I just wanted to be
with him and I still do it's very simple
she wakes up in the morning wants to be
with reaches you want to be with me
don't you Kelly replaced Kathy Lee as
the co-host in 2001. you got the best
guy I know I do I'm lucky my parents
just said I can't believe they're going
to pay you to do this it's the best job
I know he is thanks I know what Regis
was to me Rosanna he was a 15 years the
best partner a person could ever ever
have out professionally but he was my
friend we were dear friends and after I
left the show for the the next 20 years
we became better friends dearer friends
I saw him two weeks before he died we
never had an argument not an unkind word
in 15 years so that was my reality all
the years I've known him I never saw him
I'm unkind to anyone the hard thing
about it is keeping it fresh year after
year after year that's why you know and
this is our 15th year starting today
right
I get choked up when I think
for years in the book Kelly writes about
her relationship with Regis stating that
it was mostly professional and that
there wasn't much interaction off camera
but she did describe him as being warm
and friendly as well as a great
Storyteller we had a professional
working relationship and that's what we
had and that's okay because we are from
different Generations we have different
friend groups and we had different
professional backgrounds Regis had
previously admitted that the two lost
touch when he left the show in 2011. I'm
not going to say anything
ugly about anybody I wouldn't I never
have and I'm not going to start now I
just I'm just saying my reality is
something completely different from that
and now a source close to Kelly tells
E.T quote it's ironic that Kathie Lee's
comments will lead to more people buying
the book and reading the truth of what
Kelly said about Regis there is no Feud
believe me we we we're happy aren't we
hun I've been happy I've been happy I
had and still have enormous respect
admiration and reverence for Regis
I like most of the viewing public
felt like I knew him
but to expect two people from such
different generations to have some sort
of weird forced friendship when they
never knew each other is a very strange
thing to put on one person and it was
only put on one person and that is how I
describe it
[Music]
thank you